Sanford's is so good I know huh to meet
and and then there's David there too in
parentheses yeah that's really meets
David what you start a show called time
and Bart's Hemis and then you put David
in small font
yeah hey guys we'll go back to off the
record where we talk about what
my first time here ever nobody clapped
for me they even introduced me that's
wacky I'm sorry yeah
can you come for me you've been coming
and filming but I haven't been here with
you I know every time I look at the
column I know you'll do that you don't
look at the caution go like this I do
yeah in the email that might okay who's
here who's here and like polished
cautions you've seen who would you want
to take out so you could put sit yeah
remove every single [ __ ] in the
coffee you have to choose one and they
have to be like an actual person that
comes on now yeah and they have to get
on their knees and then you have to take
them out yeah yeah with a guy what cuz
you said you wanted TIFF but then you
didn't see her so she doesn't want to
tell you you are a former boss so it's a
little awkward you know what you're
putting it in this position I would say
a lot of the Thais I'm the only girl on
here so anytime any guy is replaced
that's fine because I just want at least
one guy replace I have one other girl
more girls who are you guys gonna put in
the title is it gonna be me or Julia no
one but I've been on for like two
straight lines open Julia
the bed was funny yeah we'll see more
bye you guys
I think Julia I think so too I've seen
the comments yeah well last week when I
was shooting with you guys well whenever
that was - yeah two weeks ago I did two
days in a row and Julia was on the next
day I was like oh I want to be on a
Julia day
Hey I had been on with Julian like I
don't know [ __ ] six months or some
weird [ __ ]
oh yeah we did one day together more
than me Steve was our first time in a
while like since forever ago forever ago
ya know the comments talked about you
all the time I reach like we and now
they love her but [ __ ] can we
talk about how before we take hauling
Bart said that his dick is burning so
yesterday we did the timin and Nadeem
had to eat the hot sausage take your
party on JK news no it's like a bed like
you have to finish the script in two
weeks okay as they didn't do it that the
drink the hot sauce
jakie party though I got the 1515 I like
10 oh dang so Casey got the lease I
think he's at nine ninety-two maker
[Music]
writing is not his strong suit okay okay
seumas harvard burst him up supportive
that's good he creates beautiful things
when he creates them he's just so I
really want to see what he comes up with
I'm not be amazing yeah that's not like
I happen to live here's when he's done
with that really good y'all just made me
realize that um act like 10 15 years on
YouTube I've only like the longest
sketch longest script I've ever written
is Bob like seven pages so it's like
this is like the longest should ever it
Wow and it's just getting started
wait so what's your movie about um I'm
working on a couple concepts I wanted to
do but for the bed since we only got two
weeks I was like I'm gonna work on that
what I feel is gonna be easier to write
just funnier so I'm working on like a
buddy roadtrip movie for me and David
okay it plays off sin foods so it's like
food themed but we're brothers in it
mm-hm and that's all say so it's like
sin foods plus
um racism in there yeah geez that's a
movie if you guys don't know about Davis
resume no tips randomly calls people
raised brothers would just enjoy right
she's like it's like [ __ ] and fresh off
the boat and all about all the Asian
punch
hoo-wah weights it's more like I want to
say it's like Harold and Kumar meets
onward meets goofy movie goofy movies
like voice voice he was the guy that was
in the audience and he was like the
really boggles his lines right you know
remember that I was like really really
young when I came out like really really
young okay yeah yeah goofy was just like
are you gonna cheat this movies that
mean your skits before you know but hey
guys I wrote I wrote a seven I wrote
seven pages but honestly you guys just
say one of the [ __ ] you want well no
that was because whatever hope for you
guys I know they're some of your best
[ __ ] is when you just like ripping off
each other yeah it's like I would write
my dialogue and I'd be like okay Joe
says some funny [ __ ] fill up these lines
watch some funny [ __ ] along these lines
and just go do whatever by the way
that's how [ __ ] Marvel does half of
their movies I'm not even kidding
like they they figure it out on the day
sometimes because they find something's
not working
yeah so they just throw the script away
and they start to create it really can
be have like a like a script they do it
and then they also just do the fun
because I know the offices like that way
they're like we're gonna do want to take
and then hey just do whatever you want
and it's usually those other ones that
they just have fun yeah so with the
great tits
the script is great because it gets
everyone in the location and then you
had no your actors and your props and
all that [ __ ] and then you kind of if
it's up if it's not working they just
kind of trash it there's a really
dialogue that they're playing with or
even plot points and stuff it could be
both sometimes those movies that they
figure Coast Buster's for example they
didn't have the plot like at the end
figure it out until they were on set and
they just kind of figured it out you
know who else does that rights as they
shoot money - yeah I was watching like
behind the scenes [ __ ] it's like this
sometimes the actors they'll get scripts
that day because
writers have been like tweaking things
according to a while they shoot you know
yeah pretty crazy it sounds stressful it
is true that the part at the end was
ghostbusters whether you cross the
streams they just figured that out on
the day we're yeah Wow
wait so you have dick oh yeah yeah so I
was you know handling the hot sauce and
it's with these gloves and then that
bottle it's like a little vial so the
hot sauce spills out and I didn't really
know that it was gonna last 24 hours so
earlier I was eating my sandwich and
then my sandwich is the reduced fat
turkey bacon from Starbucks it's not
spicy at all but as I was eating it my
lips started to burn on my left foot
once it's all spicy not like oh [ __ ]
it's the hot sauce I gotta pee
so I want to go pee and I held my dick
and I was that or the part I held my
biggest are burning right now hold you
bar the same gloves to hold hot sauce to
eat and to hold your dick while you pee
and then you probably went back to your
sandwich afterwards that's [ __ ] spicy
these gloves are my special eczema
gloves so I don't just have they have
silicon inside so I can't have I don't
have multiple pairs of these guys this
is hard enough
are those a little strange for you to
wear gloves because like you're the guy
that's always hot all the time and it's
summer yeah so why would you wear glove
temporary execs the most after were
these guys and then life it is but it's
manifesting temporarily I don't believe
I don't believe in these month bugs get
more out of me Wow
you know it's weird in Canada they say
eczema eczema yeah they're like oh I got
exam I need my lotion it sounds way
nicer yeah it sounds like a [ __ ]
nightclub or something big in Vegas yeah
true that's just about me too
what sounds like you know like designer
bottled water oh my god man I could go
for an eczema right now oh so refreshing
yeah did you live in Canada yeah yeah I
could leave it I mean I would you know
la is like my number one choice because
I come from LA I love LA but um I could
live in Vancouver or Toronto or like one
of the bigger cities Vancouver's like so
beautiful her fan cooler
really beautiful yeah bro nature it's
like Vancouver you can go from like
downtown really like City area and then
drive like 15-20 minutes just like
beautiful like we like you know it's a
whole bunch of trees and like crazy
views and the Asian food is really good
up there some of the best ramen I've
ever had is in Vancouver I lived it for
two months where yeah so my dad's like
kind of crazy so he grew up when he like
left I guess I went to Germany then from
Germany went to Canada just do backpacks
we met a bunch of people along the way
and like a lot hippies did it have you
already no no this is before but then
all those hippies that he met you like
lifetime friends so they all just camp
backpack nomads right so he was like I
want you to experience that too so he
sent me there with my brother and sister
to live with his friends on a boat for a
month maybe like 10 to 12 or something
what and then right when we got there
they're like they thought we were like
don't lose your dad again no we're on
the boat we're complaining it was like a
small as but it was a horrible horrible
do you get like seasick did you throw up
every day one we call her cousins were
like can you say with you guys and then
they're like yeah like do you have
cousins there too yeah yeah a family
there where they heavily insulted
because you're right next to them on a
small boat saying like yo can we get the
[ __ ]
apparently so we found out there they
were happy that we love because they
thought we were gangsters what like they
know who we were who brother doesn't her
sister as a gangster yes they just think
everyone from America were like because
they're so [ __ ] polite they're really
I love this yeah I still see them but
like back then like maybe we cursed a
little bit or whatever and they were
just like like they thought my older
brother was like I'm or ahead I was like
we're like not interesting they were
White's yeah are you talking like MTV
style yo yo yo and uh oh [ __ ] these
[ __ ] thugs
not even close heard yeah I feel like
Julie is the camping type aren't you
yeah I love Heather yeah yeah I went I
used to do it a lot when we were younger
um it was
mostly out like in Santa Margherita or
like Big Bear so we don't really go to
too far like we never camped out in the
Yosemite or like any of like like real
camping with Tenzin [ __ ] yeah
yeah that's not that's how fake happy
we're like where you park next to your
tent kind of thing yeah to me I don't
think that's wrong would you go for
what's long she would go for oh we
wouldn't go for like a week and I didn't
shower for a week shower it was great
because I remember this distinctly like
I walked into a restaurant and like a
lot of people were like looking at us
but I don't know maybe because we're the
only Asian people in there but that's
what the work well and I heard flies
walk around me and I was like like good
Cartesian form really stinky yeah yeah
the stink lines either major because I'm
really stinky and you were the only
Asians they have seen in their whole
life and I'm like man you know what
what's why do the agents [ __ ] stink
all right what a great impression was it
a Asian restaurant you walked into no it
was the Flies belong inside already know
it was like somewhere near the campsite
like on our way back home I've never
been camping like pizza tent camping
really ever do you want to like I'm I've
gone to like you know into the woods I
when I went to like Christian camp for
like two weeks and we kissed stayed in
kind of like a little dorms or something
yeah wasn't even a cabin it was like an
axe with more showers and [ __ ] you know
but I've never gone like yo let's go
[ __ ] make a fire set up a tent I want
to do that but I don't want to but I
don't want to have my car right next to
me I want to hike damn get there and
then like be near a water source that's
football and make it in afraid yeah I
want to do like that I've never done
that but I don't know so I was like my
uncle spot huh how's my uncle spot the
one I told you guys to oh it was too
civilized vice-captain right next to and
his running water yeah so this when you
go poop do you just want to use leaves
to like wipe your butt I'm gonna bring
toilet paper but I want to be able to
poop in the dirt like dig a hole
and like wash your button the river yeah
and then watch my voice why do you want
to do this this is what we have moved
away from my Native American can be with
you let's go keV England footage that's
good footage Oh y'all could get told to
get a brand new Oh fancy
oh gosh the cordilla semi is so
beautiful I sights
you can't even drive too so you have to
park your car somewhere and then you
have to go like three five seven
fourteen miles Rover to wherever the
lake is and then so a lot of those like
you'll see signs it gonna be like a
trail and I'm like like Celia
or you're not gonna be back for three
days because you can't just get that
access back to your car and you trying
to beat the Sun the locale I think
something's wrong with me
psychologically because I'm so not an
active person like yes I think I'm like
picturing myself going through that and
I'm in living hell and why would you
want to connect with their ancestral
wounds but I really want to experience
that living hell I don't know why I'm
doing this I hate working out I really
do but you love it
no no I don't I while I'm doing it I'm
like giving excuse to get out of here
and I really hate it you look like you
hate it you doing I'm pretty good you
know how much I hate working out I don't
do it I'll do like once a month and I
don't know okay look to be fair I'll do
it I'll be consistent like two or three
days and I'm like oh my god I look
amazing I'm like I feel good feel good
and then I just fall off like a month
that's how I feel about diarrhea like I
[ __ ] my brains out
oh I'm so [ __ ] scary right now man so
awesome but you look good for not
training okay so I've been told
whenever I first of all thank you thank
you but second of all I've been told by
workout guys that um like my body takes
well to working out like that I was like
dude your genetics bro if you just
[ __ ] trained man see what we did and
was like 45 years ago that one
actually watch that the other day was
like fog oh good one our death oh I know
Photoshop those pictures right
no but the video thumbnail was slightly
yeah I mean altered alter yeah I mean I
guess why'd you laugh when he said oh no
just funny that that that's what I
pictured like guys are the only ones
that gonna come up and give you
compliments alright it'll never give you
complan on your body especially at the
gym okay bro you're [ __ ] your
genetics do you let me do your genetics
I hey we won like [ __ ] that's what guys
think when they first start working out
you're like okay I'm gonna look like the
[ __ ] rock and then all these chicks
are gonna be irresistible to me and then
you worked out and then it's just dudes
like dude what's your arm program bro
nice cab what's going on with those damn
I don't know whenever I motivate myself
enough to work out it's never because I
have a vision of what my body's gonna
look like cuz I I for some reason have
like a mental block for the potential
where my body can be it's just like oh
I'm gonna look like that but my joints
weren't hurt as much or like I'll be
able to have better cardio or whatever
you know you're working out for the
right reasons weird
I envision physical manifestations gonna
look like or the capability of what your
body can look neither you're just like I
just want my [ __ ] to work no exactly
because I the thing like that the thing
that gets me to I am motivated to work
out is because like the current state my
body's in it's like I feel so gross and
then I'm like I can't move my joints
hurt like my ass is getting numb too
much animal crossing my [ __ ] elbows
hurt from doing this all the time and
then like I start feeling like the back
of my head get like whooshing lat
like the like you know like the hair
like like rice but then it's like flat
because I'm always linked okay these
things I gotta move okay I need a
[ __ ] little slaw over there you
should take the switch onto the
treadmill that's what I do Bros mystic
yes lit his house yeah
do it for month how long you on there
for about an hour that's a good amount
yeah that's great I do like 4 to 5 miles
sometimes yeah yeah I mean that's how
David said he lost weight he was just
[ __ ] like just walking like three
three miles every day I just want to get
the VR systems
that's sick yeah they have like crazy
ones now yeah I do technology for that
it's insane you know put that on the
treadmill no well they have a one that
comes with a guitar one that's 360 so
you just turn and spin so you now you
can walk it in do all those things but
it's usually like say like a room like
this and then you have the sensors and
then you have the glasses do you have a
big place to move and then people are
like actually get gas because you're
having a fight shoot do whatever the
game is we're gonna it's gonna get so
fun gyms are [ __ ] dude I don't trust it
like being I know that they're trying to
open up gyms now but like I don't trust
it people are you not gonna go no
because I'm just like I'd cope eight is
still like out and about I I don't know
it has been zero spikes from the
protests because it's been a couple days
but the way they make it seem it's like
the minute you go outside your house
you're because the current spikes right
now is because of Memorial Day weekend
you know it takes it oh so when is
barbell opening him it's open about
Tuesday
oh damn I'll be there for real I'm sure
you have to reserve got a reserved a
spot though cuz we're really trying to
follow guidelines so you can go there
from 5:00 to 7:00 7:30 to 9:30 10:00 to
12:00 to our block or reserve a spot oh
there are 35 people because it's like
280 a day I mean I do kind of want to
start weight training y'all got somebody
can train me up there yep us you trained
you well I know you busy fit so fine no
but we got trainer got a head trainer
I'll think about it
he's a beautiful man well in that case
good the access you have right now think
about it kill I'll be awesome maybe I
said other guys said I'd be awesome
yeah I mean I get content to fine
I have a voice in the back of my head
that's always like and then somebody
gets the loudest is usually when I'm the
flattest or whatever it's like you're
abusing your pieces you hear Pete [ __ ]
and then I'm like okay it's time to work
out see my voice is always like you're
[ __ ] amazing dude you don't I have
sees voice back yet it helps I just have
other people's voices telling me that oh
[ __ ] yep in real life in real life yeah
what's that you true yeah what god man
Thank You Lilith metic he's actually the
culprit my voices are just like kill
them on fire
you know Oh run the car off the road
[ __ ] like that oh [ __ ] that's really
scary dude you should actually go to
church maybe I think Julie I do still do
your dying boat stuff yeah you haven't
been able to because of it this whole
thing yeah I have and I'm going back no
I haven't done dragon boat in a long
time but I did go riding the other day
and I was like really tired just to be a
competitive rower really because it's a
shape of a dragon tell everybody yeah so
like the Winklevoss twins are people
what hundred I gave them and then
they'll skin the Dragons and they'll
create a boat out of it and then we'll
go ahead and row in the water
so uh so we'll have like one row over
here and one over here at everyone's
like responsible for one paddle that's
what voting it is it's like but you
don't know what it is so I knew skinned
the dragon wasn't real but I was like
wait wait how much of this is right I
thought she meant like skinning like a
boat talk like a dragon oh okay tell us
what it really is please yeah it's uh I
don't know it's just it's like
competitive growing innocence so you
just have like two rows of people and
each person is like responsible for a
side and you guys literally have to like
row in sync to like once if someone's
not trying as hard it is about going oh
yeah it will
yeah you can feel a difference hmm I
feel like can you pinpoint who is
lacking uh yeah because based on because
cuz he's on his phone
have their own side so one side feels
like it's lacking then you can
definitely feel the lag is like on
whichever side it is yeah so you just
yell at the whole side kind of
essentially or you just yell at the
person's like you know start stinking
with your teammates so then like
essentially you have to like stop
paddling and you just have to like go
with the momentum oh sorry I would have
like reset yeah mmm interesting that's
before you oh you're just going with
that yeah where you're wrong
well cool yeah that group yeah yeah I
haven't done that a while but do you
miss it sometimes sometimes but then
also not really
hmm welcome you don't miss it oh he's
trained with the Winklevoss my
[Music]